[Music]
let's go out to Los Angeles and talk to
Jackie what's up
Jackie hello what up how we doing hi Dr
John my husband and I are huge fans so
thanks so much for having me on thank
you so much I'm a huge fan of you Jackie
appreciate you awesome we listen to all
of your shows and you've genuinely
become like a friend to us but we just
got to say we were slightly disappointed
when we found out you were an Astros man
yuck is that is that is that just simply
because the daughters lose all the
time because because the as cheat all
the time so oh okay cool there's that
there's that well hey since uh y'all
y'all have just gone and purchased
everybody and for a billion bajillion
dollars and I hope you feel good about
yourself you know it's going to be like
I heard a comedian say this once rooting
for the Dodgers moving forward is going
to be like going to Vegas and cheering
for the house like hey go Vegas way to
go way to go Dodgers hope you're happy
with yourself you're still gonna lose
the Astros all right so what's up G
stros well so my question today is about
my
mama okay we take a hard left turn here
yep um so for as long as I can remember
I have truly felt that my mom loves my
sister more than me and I feel so silly
calling about this as almost a
30-year-old woman but um uh it it hurts
very badly um it's like a big cut in my
heart that I feel just doesn't heal
because I won't let it in so many ways
but um some of her actions that have
showed this to me include like her
saying like wow like your sister has
such a calling on her life she's so
special she's always been so special and
she says this like like right when we're
both in the same room and she'll be like
oh my gosh like my daughter is just so
beautiful isn't she Jackie and I'm like
hey I'm gorgeous and beautiful too like
um but it's like little things like this
to where like anytime my sister I get in
a little fight like it's like a silly
little fight or a big fight you know
like sisters do we're four years apart
and we we are the best of friend so hey
we fight um but she always immediately
takes her sides her side no questions
asked no questions asked it doesn't
matter if she came to my house and you
know she doesn't do this by the way but
just hypothetically if she came over my
house and she she just like completely
shattered everything I owned she would
somehow find a way to take her side um
anytime um she makes weird comments like
the other I'll give you a quick example
on like she made a little comment the
other day on how like my sister's
physically stronger than I am and I'm
like hello I've birthed two children and
she's like yeah know she's physically
stronger than you are and I know that
sounds so silly like something a
15-year-old would get upset at but
whenever I get upset at these things
it's not only that I get upset I turn
into this little 12-year-old girl and I
feel like a 10-year-old again I just
feel like a like a little child again
and my I just feel so unloved I guess I
don't know um well my question for you
is um I know that she may never change
oh by the way I may add that whenever I
bring things things up like this she
tells me that I'm crazy and she tells me
that I need to see a therapist because
I'm jealous of my sister and I can
promise you Dr John I'm not jealous of
my sister but I am jealous of my mom and
how she doesn't how special and
beautiful I am and she doesn't respect
my boundaries but she respects my
sisters how do you know how do you know
that well or let me ask you
how do you know that she doesn't tell
your sister how amazing you are that
she's already given her
grandkids or that that you're so amazing
how do you know that she's not propping
your sister up in front of you because
she sees her sister as so inferior to
the woman you've
[Music]
[Applause]
become can you can you ask that in a
different way again so I can understand
that sure yeah so
often there's a great saying by Dr Brown
Berne Brown who says what we go looking
for in the world we are sure to
find and so there could
be there could be some objective reality
here okay like my brother is a Kinder
man than me he just is he is disposition
he's so
kind and if my mom was to say you're
brother's Kinder than you that's a
that's an objective fact he really is
yeah yeah and so if your Mom is saying
she's stronger than you in front of both
of you that could be true that could be
true or like uh any number of things she
makes more money than you she's more
successful than you yeah that I mean if
you look at our tax returns she makes
more money like that could all be true
yeah but what I want to just put in the
in the universe as a
potential is is it possible that when
your mom and your sister are alone your
mom is asking her why don't you have
grandkids yet your sister's given me two
wonderful beautiful
grandkids what about you your sister's
already been married and already has
this and this what about
you you see what I'm saying yeah totally
absolutely does that happen or no chance
um no okay all right there's no way yeah
um I was just trying but
no no in some ways and I totally get
what you're saying I was actually going
to add this on my notes I'm like dude I
am I'm like totally okay with my sister
being more beautiful she is she like
physic you know that is a truth that is
a truth in the world and I'm I'm the big
sister I you know I I'm the type of
person I'm like my sister I when I say
she's my best friend I'm like girl I
want you to do better than me in every
area of my life I truly mean that it's
like it's more of
like what do you get from
this what do you mean you are hanging
you hang on to something this
relationship with your mom where she
belittles you treats you like you're
still an elementary school kid that
lives in her home that pits uh you
versus your best friend SLS sister SL um
Confidant you get something from this
interaction otherwise you'd bail what is
it h you know what I because you
wouldn't put up with a boyfriend that
treated you like this no I would not and
my husband tells me that all the time
yeah so what what are you getting from
this you know what I I do enjoy our
relationship for the most part but she
just crosses my boundaries so much she
just I feel like she had has no respect
for me she clear list Let Me Clear has
none none okay she doesn't and when you
bring it up she says you're crazy yeah
and she says you're the problem you go
fix it yeah what are you getting from
this nothing just pain in my heart
that's probably not true yeah well no I
mean I love her she I I I enjoy I think
she's one of the most wonderful people
I've ever met and to give you I know
this is no excuse for you I listen to
your show but um her Aces score is an
eight and the only reason it's not a 10
is because she was an orphan and she
didn't have parents to be divorced or be
abusive so she's gone through so much
where I that doesn't give her that
doesn't give her a pass on how she
treats you it just doesn't yeah and it's
not your job to make sure she's okay for
the rest of her life as and and as her
doormat yeah it's not and that's how I
feel always as a big older child just
like a
doormat I I've always just felt like a
doormat like she just
um um she she'll come into my home and
just immediately criticize I don't know
why I did not plan on crying on the show
hard it's hard it's hard it's okay it's
okay so let me ask you what are you
getting from
this I'll tell you what you're getting
you're getting a fantasy
that one day you're going to do the
right thing and finally fix
this and that day is never going to
come and you hang on and you hang on and
you hang
on there's not going to be an amount of
money that you make there's not going to
be a car that you drive up in that your
mom finally goes my God I'm so proud of
you
Jackie
it's not going to come is it
[Applause]
nope that's why you keep showing up you
keep showing up maybe this version is
going to be okay maybe the next version
is going to be okay maybe the next
version of the view is going to be
okay and meanwhile you have this husband
at home that loves you so much right so
much he's like honestly awesome just the
best yes and he's like man what why do
you keep going back to this woman he
always tells me that he's like dude what
are you doing like yeah listen you're
trying to close a loop and you're not
broken every child on planet Earth does
it everyone does it because we all ask
that question why not
me mom why don't you love me and your
mom tells you well you're not pretty
enough you're not make this much you
don't have purpose you don't have this
your house my God what are you doing
with your house in your car that's what
you
drive and you think it's about that
checklist that somehow you can solve
that
checklist and you've probably you've
been around long enough half of your
life now from 12 to 12 to 30 let's say
more than half your life every time you
click something off that checklist like
two more boxes end up at the bottom of
the list it just keeps growing you can
never finish
it because it's not about you it's about
your
mom and and my guess is she sees herself
in you and when she sees herself in you
she sees that girl that grew up in
absolute
hell and her way of trying to make that
Cycle
Stop was to control every second of your
life and then beautiful fairy godsister
comes along and screws it up for
everybody
right yeah so here's my big question are
you ever going to sit down across the
table from your mom and say Mom if you
do X and Y and Z again then what you're
asking me is to not come around your
home
anymore are you ever going to do that
and that's not a it's not a setup
question that's not a it's not like a
dare I'm just asking is that is that day
ever gonna
come H you know I've done I've had this
conversations before and it's like um it
worked it was like a certain situation
with the grandkids and I straight up
told told her hey if you do this again
and my husband had to step in he's like
hey if you do this again you can't if
you talk to my wife this way you cannot
come into my home and because it had to
do with the grandkid she was like oh
immediately I mean it's been she didn't
cross a boundary for years and so it
seems like it's time for that talk again
but it's like she it's like she almost
stopped honoring those boundaries but
she started um doing it in a more subtle
way now so it's a little bit harder for
me to call out but I am to answer your
question am willing to do that talk but
I just hate having those I hate
confrontation man I just oh yeah dude
yeah no no kids like oh I can't wait for
this one that's the worst here's why I
ask you this if you have that in every
five years you have to sit down and have
a refresher or every five years your
daughters are going to get a little bit
older and a little bit older and so the
things are going to shift and change a
little bit
okay if that's a price to pay for your
kids having a good grandmother and my
guess is she's probably a good
grandmother to which makes this whole
thing annoying right he's like the best
in the world that's the worst come on
yeah okay so let me let me be real
honest and you know this at some point
this turns on one of your
daughters yeah one of your daughters
becomes the favorite and one of them
doesn't yeah and we're not going to let
this happen
again yeah you've already lived this
yeah okay it's going to show up in
Christmas presents for one over the
other it's going to show up in dresses
it's going to show up in comments it's
going to show up in all sorts of things
right yeah
okay here's the other side of
it
um you can spend a season
exhaling clenching your fist real tight
and then relaxing it and saying to
yourself she doesn't get a
vote she doesn't get a vote and that
sounds so tried at first but if that
becomes something you practice over time
yeah I'm able to be in the presence of
people who have so many opinions about
me and I honestly don't care I don't
care but I took me a decade to get there
I had to practice
Yeah I had to practice and occasionally
somebody says something man I don't
sleep for days I
don't but it's a
practice because all the other good that
comes with them being in the room is
worth whatever stupid things they going
to say about me or my boss or my friend
or my whatever I don't
care but it took years of me saying you
don't get a vote yeah you don't get a
vote or when she says your sister's so
beautiful you grab your sister by the
face and say I know I'm so lucky to be
her big sister yeah I'm gonna go right
with
it your sister do that it's it's like it
roasts in the I'm like hey I I do and I
agree but then after I'm like hey like
hearing this every
single day or like every other day you
know I'm like oh it it starts to hurt my
feelings very badly yeah so what we're
not going to do is we're not going to
let Mom hurt her feelings anymore uhhuh
she doesn't have that right anymore
she's lost she's cashed out that right
your husband he still has permission to
hurt your feelings okay he's your right
or die yeah um You probably have one or
two best friends your sister maybe
that's a small crew I think in my little
little box I've got about six MH six
dudes and one woman who I've given
permission like you can call and cut me
to the court
mhm other than that man you can
frustrate me you can let me have a bad
day you can I mean you can you can push
me into a bad day you can whatever hurt
me
financially but you're not I'm not going
to give you access to hurt my feelings
you don't get that you don't get
that so let me hear let me say this
Jackie you're not
crazy I think you need to I I tell
everybody to do this I feel like but I
think it's really instructive here I
would love for you to write a letter to
12 real
Jackie when the whole world figured out
that your younger sister was
beautiful and your mom was trying to
process having two daughters after
growing up in a lifetime of
Hell write a letter to 12-year-old
Jackie and just say hey you're a good
kid and you didn't deserve any of this
stuff write a letter to 22-year-old
Jackie who met this knuckleheaded
husband of yours who fell in love and
mom didn't approve mom kept talking
about how great sister was let her know
that she's loved
and then write a letter to 30-year-old
Jackie the woman you're about to become
and by the way you want to be a gangster
read it to your husband out
loud let him know how important his love
is to you
also but you have to make peace with
12-year-old Jackie and 21-year-old
Jackie and 18-year- old Jackie and
30-year-old Jackie and stop Outsourcing
that peace to Mom because you're not
going to get it from
her that call will never
come
and that doesn't mean there's not
peace hang on the line I'm going to send
you a copy of own your past change your
future I think it'd be a good book for
you to to work
through